hi everyone uh today i had a great
pleasure talking to
none other than dr professor god
sod of concordia university
uh where he is the
concordia university research chair in
evolutionary behavioral sciences and
darwinian consumption
and he is at the john mulson school of
business at concordia university we
talked about
dozens of things today it was quite
interesting he gave me a couple of
exclusives
just exclusive to the into the
impossible podcast i hope you'll enjoy
that
we talked about the different kinds of
ideas idea pathogens that he calls them
he talked about different
ways that academia is being influenced
the sciences
are being afflicted by these various uh
mind viruses for lack of a better word
uh
he's he's a master of the uh of the uh
neologism coining new words like ostrich
parasitic syndrome
collective munchism syndrome by proxy
nomological networks of cumulative
evidence and uh how their interest
involved with the quest for truth
we talked about other things that he's
involved with he's very prolific on
twitter on youtube
uh you probably have found me only
through him uh but he's
uh he's quite a fascinating person uh
mesmerizing
uh to talk to similar in some of the
other ways to different ideas that i've
had on the show uh
from from people ranging from uh dave
rubin and michael shermer
uh and beyond uh and i think what's
what's that sets him apart
is that he is uh he's really a true
scientist
uh in the sense that he's actively
conducting research
into ways to alleviate these kind of
itches that he has intellectual itches i
call them
that he cannot scratch other than to do
the research himself so
i found him incredibly uh interesting we
even got into
god g-o-d not g-a-d and you'll hear more
about that i hope you enjoy
this wide-ranging interview with none
other than dr god sad
any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from magic
[Music]
hello and welcome everybody i've had on
many different types of guests i've been
very blessed and fortunate to have on
nobel prize winners
macarthur geniuses a pulitzer prize
winner
and even a fool even an abject [ __ ]
that was when i did a solo episode
featuring just myself but today this is
my first god i've got god here
and yes it is none other than the god's
only truth i'm going to read this
gentleman's
this gentleman's biography and i'll tell
you a little bit about his book
and then i'm going to uh hopefully if
he's game for it
deal with some fun provocative things
around his uh his
very very interesting new book called
the parasitic mind and that's dr god sod
he is a professor of marketing and the
concordia reese
university research chair in
evolutionary behavioral sciences
and darwinian consumption i want to
learn more about that
i didn't know darwin had tuberculosis
but that actually he held from 2008 uh
for
a decade until 2018 he's uh at the john
mulson school of business is that
related to moles and beer we got to
figure that out
okay that makes sense i went to uh
anheuser-busch university once at uh at
sea world and i
i got rejected uh for my phd quest there
um today we're going to talk about uh
his new book uh
which is called the the parasitic mind
and i wanted to say a few more words
about him he's incredibly prolific he's
written
for hundreds literally hundreds of
academic rigorous academic
journal articles he's written for
psychology today
he's the proprietor of the sad truth uh
youtube channel and podcast on itunes
and elsewhere
and we only have 30 minutes for the
interview so now we're done god
unfortunately
your your effusiveness that is required
to introduce you
has taken up all of our time no uh god
welcome to the into the impossible
podcast
thank you so much for having me brian
it's a real pleasure to be with you i'm
so glad we got connected through our
mutual friend michael shermer uh who's
uh who's also been
on the show and whose book is somewhere
behind me over there as yours will join
i want to start off with the book
and if you indulge me i'm going to do
two things i'm going to read some
some blurbs that you've received i'm
going to read some five star blurbs that
you've received
and i'm going to read your lowest star
blurb that you've received on amazon
i've never done this before in the
podcast
and these are only by the way these are
only verified reviews i don't believe in
reading
unverified loser reviews that people
don't read the book and
and give it either a good or a bad uh
review but the first review i'm going to
read for god comes from not only
none other than god himself g o d
and that's as said the following god
said of god
blessed be he who enlarges god so you
can put on weight
uh god crouches like a lion he tears off
arm and scalp
he chose the best of the land for
himself for there a commander's portion
was reserved
and he came with the heads of the people
with israel
he executed the justice of the lord and
his judgments for israel
i thought this was kind of interesting
because a lot of what you do
is the satire done with a surgeon's
scalpel
but the way that god is describing the
tribe of god in the
in the torah as the old testament as we
would say uh
is uh is that you're using a scalp
you're tearing off limbs and arms
which is the real god saw do you do you
come with a scalpel or do you cut with a
cleaver
uh you know if i can speak of myself in
the third person
god is multifaceted i can
tuck my children to bed with all of the
love that one might imagine
and i can be viciously violent if you
attack me in an
alley and try to rape my wife nothing
changes in who i am it's the situation
that changes right
now this is by the way something in
psychology we refer to as the
fundamental attribution error
whereby should you attribute a
phenomenon
to a dispositional trait or to a
situational trade and oftentimes
the fundamental attribution error is
exactly that so so if you see me say
something
spicy to someone on twitter rather than
saying well maybe the situation demanded
it because this person has been
insulting me non-stop for a week
with me being restrained you say oh my
god
god sad seems so elegant when he spoke
at stanford
but he's such a nasty buffoon on twitter
no i'm not
it's different types of engagement so
sometimes i use satire when it requires
it
and sometimes i can be as elitist and
academic as you
need me to be
you had gotten a lot of derision from
the staid
confines of the faculty clubs around the
world including perhaps concordia maybe
elsewhere
and that was for going on joe rogan and
being uh
one of his most successful top guests
and you know i i always i never know how
to really confront those people because
people say things oh joe rogan's a clown
he's just a camille
a fear factor guy and why is a serious
chair
named chair professor like dad or you
know i i've never been on uh joe's show
but um but
you know i wouldn't wouldn't turn it
down it would be a step down from some
of the podcasts that i've been up
i'm willing to lower myself but then i
pointed out last week that uh he's had
on a nobel prize winner in physics uh
sir roger penrose for hours talking
about the deepest uh most meaningful
subjects you can imagine
as well as people like our friends eric
weinstein sean carroll
lawrence kraut you know brilliant
brilliant scientists controversial in
the case of some of them
but nonetheless i don't think you can
say that anymore that you know joe rogan
is a venue
for the pure isle clown set anymore and
so i want to commend you for for
for being somebody who reaches out
actually let's get into that quickly
before we get to the blurbs
um do you feel like it's an obligation
for scientists in particular to learn
how to communicate the
wonders the majesty of what we do in a
in a professional way in the same way we
learn how to teach quantum mechanics
should we not be taught how to
communicate effectively as you so do
i do think it should be part of the one
of many hats that
scientists should wear now i recognize
that not
every academic is as
naturally talented in being able to
traverse
the different media right most academics
learn how to communicate within the
rarified world of their templates
they're the academic journal which is
perfectly fine we're supposed to do
original peer-reviewed research and
that's fine the problem comes when
you're unable to take
this wonderful work that you do and
excite the masses i can't tell you the
number of people who've written to me
subsequent to appearing on some joe
rogan episode saying look i decided to
go and study
evolutionary psychology consumer
psychology psychology of decision making
because i saw you on joe rogan and i saw
the passion with which
you described your field and that you
know uh
light lit up a passion in me and so i
always tell people look we are in the
currency of creating knowledge and
spreading knowledge right it's not just
creating knowledge
and only having three of our colleagues
and their mom read it right
it's about spreading it to as many
people as possible
so the the person at stanford the story
that you referred to earlier was a story
that took place when i was invited to
the stanford business school to speak
and the person who had taken me out to
dinner the night before
my talk the next day was you know
looked at with great derision at my
appearing on joe rogan right
he said something to the effect of well
you know at stanford we don't do
research so that we can
discuss it on joe rogan to which i had
literally answered so you think that
having your research covered in front of
20 million people
is not as impressive as a paper that
will be read by you
the reviewers the editor and your mom
and that pretty much set the whole uh
tone of the rest of the evening i mean
he was a nice guy
but that again speaks to that elitism
that
is so common within the ivory tower and
i despise it i hate it
yeah especially since you know a book
like you've written or you know i've
been uh
um you know fortunate to have a book
that i've written that i shamelessly
plug in every scene and every part of my
office that i'm currently in
uh losing the nobel prize get yours in
paperback wherever books are sold
uh but but the fact is for um on one
hand we can write a scientific paper and
you've written many of them
uh that will be read by yeah a dozen
people maybe and maybe each sentence
will take a month to write or a chart or
a
or some data or some analysis or we can
write a book which you know we can write
maybe
in a year maybe less i'm curious about
your writing process we'll get into that
later
uh but uh but how do you gauge the
return on impact in other words
why shouldn't you write these books
which are full of research and
actually extensively well document i was
relieved i have to say god i listened to
it i bought the audiobook the kindle
version and your publisher
sent me the printed book and i was
relieved when i got it because i'm
reading like three books a week now
amidst you know teaching graduate
students and homeschooling kids here
but i was i was you know relieved to see
it in one sense because there was like
20 pages of footnotes citations and
references so why not just
write books all day because you know
let's be honest it's not like a book
that's written for the popular audience
that
the way that you write with citations
and footnotes is not academically
researched so why not just do that
well because in a sense i might my
contract both to myself and to my
profession
is to hopefully do all of these
different things right
uh but i have to tell you that the the
older i get and the more that i advance
in my career
it is becoming increasingly more
difficult
to spend three years working on a
peer-reviewed paper
that if it is incredibly successful will
be cited by a hundred people
yes when i could literally open up my
uh youtube channel speak in front of the
camera about something really important
not not
not when i'm just joking around right
but even incidentally my humor usually
has a serious bend to it
but and then it will be watched by 65
000 people so
i think in a world of uh you know
trade-offs uh i can certainly see as i
progress in my career
having to make these tough choices i
don't think i'll ever
quit writing peer-reviewed papers
because i remain excited in the same way
that i was when i just came out of my
phd to
to actually collect data analyze it
sometimes you're disappointed because it
didn't work out sometimes you're
excited because your hypothesis looks
like it's going to work out
uh but you're right writing books for
the masses
is intoxicating because of true i mean i
don't know if you saw me on my social
media i've been doing this thing where
people post where they are opening their
my book from in bolivia and in chile and
in palestinian territory
germany yeah and in germany and in
puerto rico and dominican republic
well you know i'd like to see how many
academics have their peer-reviewed
papers read in
some little village in puerto rico so
from that perspective yes it's very
intoxicating
yeah i always enjoy getting emails from
fans that i'll never meet you know from
from pakistan and here's a devout muslim
woman and she's reading a book by this
new york
jew about the nobel prize you know and
it's saying that it's had a tremendous
impact on her
and you know i hope i can meet her
someday but but it's it's the leverage
of the written word and we'll get into
that in the end what i call the final
five questions which will take up the
remaining 80 minutes of the conversation
that you've allotted to me i have as
much time as you need
okay well don't yeah you might regret
that guys um so i do want to talk about
the book and i always say
uh i ignore the advice to not judge
books by their cover i
i always judge all books by their cover
uh you've got your copy above your left
shoulder over there in your office we
can see it i'll flash up i'll make a
bigger version of it on the screen when
we publish this
um tell me what is the meaning of the
design of the parasitics mine's cover
and how did you come up with the title
and the subtitle
so the uh the actual design is from the
art director
it basically refers to someone who is
you know manipulating your brain
the idea being that these parasitic
these idea pathogens
cause you to behave in my adaptive ways
so that's the general
the the color at first i was concerned
about
and so my only feedback when i saw the
first and you know installment of this
design was
do we really want this kind of neon
color should would not be a bit more
austere
and then they insisted that no the image
that they had i think it's just
a stock image with the color and so on
was exactly right and so i acquiesced
and
it looks like people like it do you like
the cover yeah it's very it's very
striking you know a lot of books are
very bland and you
yeah you don't really uh pick them off
but i i have a
couple of comments maybe a mild critique
about the meaning of the title because
to me the title uh is not 100 reflective
of what the book is about the book is
about not the mind as sort of a parasite
but ideas so i was wondering why is it
not the entitled the parasitic
meme or the parasitic idea you spend an
awful lot of time talking about
dawkins's concept of memetic
uh activity etc so
i mean i could have called it the
parasitized mind
parasitic sounds you know a bit easier
and it simply refers to the fact that
minds can be
the purveyors of nonsense and can also
be the ones that are the
receptacles of the nonsense how
infectious ideas are killing common
sense well
what i'm arguing just so you can get a
sense of what i mean by parasites
so as an evolutionary psychologist i
often look
to homologies and analogies and other
species
when i'm trying to make a statement
about human cognition so for example if
i'm studying
uh the sex specificity of toy
preferences
there are studies that have looked at
how verve monkeys rhesus monkeys and
chimpanzees
exhibit the same sex specific toy
preferences that humans do
so one of the tools that evolutionists
use
when making statements about human
cognition is to engage in what's called
comparative psychology
you compare human psychology to other
animals so because of that
and since i was thinking about writing a
book about these parasitic ideas
i delved into the literature of
neuroparasitology
are you do you know what that is well
i've learned it from your book yeah so
exactly so neuroparasitology is
basically the study of parasitology but
where the
parasite instead of let's say going to
your intestine which would be say a
tapeworm
it looks for the host's brain to
reside in and i give a few examples but
there are many many others
of how a brain worm or brain parasite
can cause the infected animal to engage
in deeply maladaptive ways so it could
be for example an
ungulate a moose a deer that
when it's parasite by a particular brain
worm it starts engaging in circling
behavior so it kind of bobs its head
it can't extricate itself from this
motor behavior and even if the looming
predators are coming it is stuck in this
pattern
or toxoplasma gandhi the mouse that is
infected with this parasite
loses its innate fear of cats and it
becomes attracted to the
cat's urine not a good outcome and so i
take these
principles from neuroparasitology and i
argue that humans can be
parasitized by another agent of this
of neural destruction in this case i
call these idea pathogens
but instead of leading us to the
proverbial cat it leads us to the abyss
of infinite lunacy so that's where the
parasite
and the title comes from i see and so
now going back to uh some of the reviews
we've had
god's review but now i want to do a
verified five-star review this is from
amazon customer i don't know if you know
uh him or her
amazon customer i was gonna name one of
my kids amazon customer
but this is a uh this is a verified
three star review and that was the
lowest i could find so mazel tov on that
that is uh
you know that if they're giving me three
stars they're naturally lobotomized
nothing else can make sense
that's right well you know i always love
the like one star
you know that's unverified that just you
know says this book is
terrible and that's it and they
obviously haven't read it but this
person
assuming uh they're they're uh correct
that the amazon verification button is
right he says or she says i was so
excited to receive my copy of the
parasitic mind by godsot
i had long been supported by ideas to
push back on id of efforts to push back
on ideas
the likes of post-modernism social
justice political correctness identity
politics etc
these ideas have translated into policy
could be corrosive to our western
culture
and the cohesion of our societies plural
so upon opening the book i was primed to
sympathize with the discussion of the
ideas and issues
and solutions my cognitive reasoning
faculties were tuned up
and ready to process what i thought
would be some logical evidence-based
common sense
making it didn't take long to shatter my
enthusiasm
starting on page 25 god said start
talking setting
started setting the stage for his
arguments by talking about two main ways
people process messages
he contends that the central processing
route is cognitive logical
in nature while the peripheral method is
effective
emotional i'm not sure where the
prioritization comes from maybe it's a
scientific background
but i believe that most people
non-scientists are indeed logical
but that logic is tempered if not
completely dominated by our emotional
faculties
so we could go on i don't want to uh but
uh but
what it seems thoughtful it seems a
person you know was
willing to engage it wasn't a a hater
one of these stanford professors that
you
were talking about earlier um uh so i
guess they're contending against the
dichotomy that you're laying out
and the supposition that this reviewer
is making is that most people are
logical even if they're not scientists
uh what say you yes yeah i mean i
haven't read this review and i haven't
seen the rest of it so i'm basing on
whatever you just read yeah i'm actually
not
contending that there are only binary
systems as a matter of fact i have a
term
which i refer to in the book as
epistemological dichotomania
which is kind of putting everything into
nice
pigeonholed dichotomies nature versus
nurture reasoning versus
feeling and so on what i'm arguing there
with the central versus peripheral
is i'm not saying that scientists use
central and the non-scientists use
peripheral
this person completely missed the point
when you're engaging in
persuasion attempt you can either
trigger people's cognitive mindset
and that's called the central route of
persuasion here are the 17 reasons
why you should purchase my mutual fund
that would be called central
processing peripheral processing would
be what you would typically see in a
commercial for an a perfume right you
are trying to sell me a hedonic product
and so you don't usually say here are
the 17 biochemical reasons why harvard
professors think you should
buy this perfume because that wouldn't
work very well
right because it has to sell mystery sex
and so on right and therefore in this
case you activate
the peripheral root of persuasion so you
show a beautiful girl with her hair
flowing
on a horse and then you just say mister
right
so it's not that one is superior to the
other it's that
depending on the context will determine
which of the two systems you should use
but that is part of a bigger point that
i'm making
in that chapter which is to argue that
the dichotomy between
thinking versus feeling is an incorrect
one
humans are not thinking animals or
humans are
emotional animals we are both what
matters is that you trigger the right
system at the right time so
when i am going down a dark alley to
take a shortcut home
and i see four young men loitering
around and my heart starts to race and i
get nervous
that fear response that emotional
response makes perfect adaptive sense
if i'm trying to solve one of professor
keating's
physics exams all of the emotions in the
world is not going to get me to do well
on that exam
so it's not that we are one or the other
it's that just make sure to trigger the
right system at the right time
now why am i talking about all this in
that chapter because
what i then argue is that of course
people do misapply
this system in the wrong time so when
i'm trying to decide whether to choose
donald trump or not it should be based
on
the totality of his positions and then
if i were to do that maybe i would think
that donald trump is my guy
but what most of my highfalutin super
nuanced progressive thinker friends
think is that
he disgusts me he repulses me
he's grotesque so every one of those
descriptors
is triggering their affective system
right
so i could do an experiment where i take
what donald trump said
versus what barack obama said i won't
tell them
which one said what so i remove
the specific person and the reality is
that obama has probably never uttered a
single word
that is anything other than
platitudinous vacuous [ __ ]
but my god he says it with such cadence
with such a mellifluous voice
he must be a brilliant guy this is what
i call let me
assume for a second this is the cork of
the wine bottle there's an expression in
arabic that says that
you get drunk by simply smelling the
cork of the wine bottle what does this
mean
arabic is a very flowery metaphorical
language
it means that you're so weak-minded
that i can get you to get drunk not by
actually drinking the wine by simply
drinking
by smelling the cork and this is what
happens
with a lot of the discussion about
politics it has nothing to do with
policies
so you could have one of my friends who
has been railing against islam
for his entire career but then when it
comes to choosing between trump and
another candidate
on which trump would score much better
in terms of islam
he loses that logic he discu
trump discusses what i'm saying yeah i
see
i see a lot of cognitive dissonances
that your book discusses and in my mind
uh the one you know minor criticism i
should say that the next
lowest rating of your book god and i
aspire to this in
in my next book um you know which will
be i don't know losing the pulitzer
prize
who knows uh you didn't spit out your
vodka so i think that was good uh
you did it you didn't think it was a
complete joke
but my uh but the next lowest rating
book calls you
the savior of the west so if we could
all get such you know ha levi we could
get all get such uh
poor reviews but i want to push he's
understating my importance but i
appreciate that
yeah there's uh you know modesty is the
better part of valor right so
i want to uh push back a little bit on
the dichotomy that that
both the previous reviewer kind of
hinted to
but also this notion that i found in the
book that um the veneration of science
and scientists and i almost think that
that previous reviewer
who's sort of saying that scientists are
logical and the rest of us are
normally thought of as emotional but
we're actually logical
i actually push back on the scientific
side we hear a lot of things in the
united states now trust scientists
you know trust science trust scientists
i i should say and you're a scientist
too
i don't know a scientist who trusts
another scientist first of all
oftentimes trust science trust scientist
means obey scientists at least
in the way that they're trying to
categorize it i don't obey anybody i
i think for myself i reason for myself i
have
immense amounts of education and
interest and where i'm not educated i
always say
i gave a speech on tuesday night and
somebody asked me um well
what do you think about global warming
and you're a physicist
and and you know you've you've uh you've
obviously thought about it yeah i had
ben shapiro on my show he talked about
global warming what do you think about i
said
i hope someday when you invite a climate
scientist to give a lecture
uh and then someone in the question and
answer period asks him or her
uh about the origin of the universe in a
big bang and the
probability of the multiverse they don't
just say um well
here's my opinion they say consult a
cosmologist you know professor keating
is a cheap date so give them a call
but instead you know it's it's almost
felt like because we have the letters
phd after our name or in front of my
twitter handle as the case may be
that we're somehow you know these
walking wikipedias and i always say
science means knowledge it does not mean
wisdom so
in your book you talk a lot about
trusting the scientific method karl
popper etc first tell me
what is uh what is your viewpoint do you
really believe that scientists
inherently have sort of an upper a a
natural
inoculation against parasitic mind
viruses
uh absolutely not as a matter of fact
every single idea pathogen that i
discuss
in the book stems from academics
so in other words it takes but
scientists or or
are not no i didn't say scientists
because i said academics which is a more
general term
right because oftentimes they're from
the social sciences
from there but this this is not to
denigrate them it's not to say
there's a hierarchy where the uh
professor of philosophy somehow ranks
lower than the physicist
but what i'm saying is i'm using the
broader term because usually these ideas
did not originate with chemists
right or with ecologists they originated
from
academics because it takes intellectuals
to come up with some of the dumbest
ideas right
so uh so so it is absolutely
not the case that just because you're an
academic or a scientist
you are inoculated and the problem the
reason why that's
what i just said is vertical is because
the brilliance of many of these idea
pathogens is that it can
penetrate all of your education and
knowledge
in insidious ways so in the same way
that an actual
virus is brilliant in its machinery so
that it can find a way into your cell so
that it can use your own machinery to
replicate itself
that's what these idea pathogens do now
how do they do it so maybe we can get
into
some of the idea pathogens if you'd like
is this something
yeah yeah let's do it so
i discussed many idea passages i'll
maybe discuss one or two here and
if we have time we can do some more so
for example postmodernism is the grand
daddy of all idea pathogens because it
is a form of intellectual terrorism it
negates the possibility that there is
objective truth everything is shackled
by subjectivity
everything is shackled by my personal
biases so there's no need for me to get
out of bed in the morning because
you and i you and i do wake up in the
morning thinking that there are
certain regularities in the world that
we are trying to uncover if not there'd
be no point doing anything
now of course science is provisional in
that what we thought was true
300 years ago might get updated science
is autocorrective so it's not a revealed
truth and we're done
mic dropped but it is that we do think
that there are things to be discovered
so
post-modernism is is the granddaddy of
idea pathogens for that reason
but then there are many other uh
idea pathogens that are specific to
certain fields so for example militant
feminism
is an idea pathogen that starts off
from an with a noble objective
equity feminism is a great idea men and
women should be equal under the law
there is no reason why they where we
should ever tolerate institutional
uh you know sexism the problem then
becomes that
you push it further you say in the in
the furtherance of that
social goal we should murder and rape
truth how do we do that
we reject the possibility that men and
women might be different we reject the
possibility that there are biological
differences between men and women we
reject the possibility that there are
evolutionary reasons
why men and women might evolve certain
differences
we must promulgate the idea that they
are indistinguishable so in the service
of an original noble
goal we end up murdering truth and each
of the idea pathogens that i discuss in
the book
has that same signature it starts off
with a kernel of truth
it starts off with a noble cause and in
the pursuit of that noble
cause well if we kill truth so be it
that's a consequence of the
higher objective of pursuing social
justice no
i could chew gum and walk at the same
time i could
protect transgender rights while also
not being comfortable in teaching
children
that boys to menstruate so
when we think about uh the notion of of
um taking the scientific method
as sort of this auto-corrective process
then
there by presumption is something it's
correcting against and i'm sitting here
at university of california san diego
you're at uc irvine for many years
um you might know or maybe you don't
that there was a covenant here in la
jolla
that precluded jews blacks and mexicans
from owning
real estate and that it was impossible
for a jew or black or mexican so
actually the house that i own
uh you know is not would not have been
possible for me to own
way back when and the university
actually worked against that but many
other universities didn't work
so well in fact against women against
jews
people always point out well do you
think the nobel prize committee
has had this conversation with heather
mcdonald not too long ago
and she said well do you think
scientists would really suppress
somebody just because they're black and
i said well
you know the nobel prize had a committee
on aryan science
that actively worked to deny albert
einstein the rightfully deserved nobel
prize
that he would later win only 20 you know
17 years after the invention of
relativity
uh but he would win it for another
subject that wasn't related to
relativity specifically because
hitler's chief of aryan physics a man by
the name of philip lenard
basically had an unwritten rule that was
uh
einstein could not win a nobel prize and
because previous winners of the nobel
prize are eligible
to nominate future winners there's the
matthew effect that takes over
and so no jews would really win it for
many many decades so
i said you know do you think that
science is time translation
invariant or not in other words are
scientists not the same are there
not prejudice no black has ever won the
nobel prize in physics or chemistry
and and i wonder we venerate these
institutions but
there is some legitimacy to pass in uh
injustices against jewish people against
blacks mexicans women
um you couldn't get a job maria mayor
who's over my shoulder over here
she's the first american woman to win a
nobel prize she couldn't get a job
as a professor uh for decades until uc
san diego where i am now hired her so
what do you make of that there must have
been an origin of it and why do you
think that was only in the 1960s it
wasn't 100 years ago
do you think it's invidious racism
sexism has truly been eliminated from
the sciences
so i think this speaks to probably a
dichotomy in this case we were taught
earlier talking about epistemological
dichotomy but here's a
a an important dichotomy between
equality of opportunities and equality
of outcomes right
a lot of the examples that you've
discussed is where you had
a lack of equality of opportunities
there was institutional mechanisms
that did not allow certain people
because of certain traits that they had
in many cases immutable traits from
being able to be equal participants
in whichever human endeavor we're
talking about and of course that's wrong
and we've tried as best as we can it
doesn't mean it's been fully eradicated
but to get rid of that of course the
problem though is that
in today's zeitgeist today's reality
we're not talking about equality of
opportunities we're talking about
equality of
outcome of outcomes so uh princeton
university does not have
a full professor in their math
department who is black
aha racism you follow what i mean
no there could be 63 000 other reasons
why that empirical reality holds
so we need to be careful in
differentiating between these two
the examples that you gave were
historical grievances
historical wrongdoings based on a lack
of equality of opportunities
today's die religion which is the
acronym that i use for describing
diversity
inclusion and equity has nothing to do
with equality of opportunities
and everything to do with equality of
outcomes that's grotesque
that is antithetical to an ethos of a
meritocracy right
uh shared professorships right now are
no longer granted
as a function of how impressive one cv
is they are
literally granted in the grant in the
call for that professorship
in terms of whether you hold a
particular immutable marker or not
surely we don't support that so in the
service of getting rid of past
historical grievances
we don't create a new reality based on
new grievances right yeah so i mean just
to gently push back on that i've never
been in a committee where i've been told
you have to hire a black lesbian it just
has never
it's never come up uh that that has to
be now there are diversity goals we have
it
you have it i'm sure i don't know
whether it's it's more strongly
you know kind of impressed upon faculty
in canada or
or in america but uh but in fact i've
never been told i have to hire a woman
for the and i've been the chair of many
searches
i've been involved with it and i've gone
out of my way
to actually try to recruit people from
it's very difficult especially at
younger universities like the university
of california san diego
we we started in 1960 we don't have
alumni like
even berkeley or ucla do where we had
african americans
that were graduating in the 1800s we
just don't have that legacy yet so we
work really hard and by the way
many of the people that we try to hire
it's not like they don't get a job
we try to hire you know uh uh uh african
americans all the time
it's incredibly important and they it's
not that they don't get hired or we
they go to harvard or they they go you
know and we're always competing against
you know very very uh well-funded
especially private institutions that
have a lot of resources to devote to
this
so it's frustrating but i do want to
push back in the sense that
um currently the first um the first
black phd
from from mit's theoretical physics is a
good friend of mine he's been on the
podcast
his name is sylvester james gates he's
the ford foundation professor at brown
university my alma mater
and uh he's brilliant now he's he pushes
back and he's
you know he has had um episodes you know
frequently throughout his history
of of racist behavior against him as
suppression i mean he graduated from mit
in
1978 as the first african-american
um uh phd in theoretical physics he's
the father of string of
super symmetry why did it you know why
does it take so long and why
you know these these eminent
institutions like mit
harvard etc which had a long history of
anti-semitism and
quota system and still does has a quota
system uh
allegedly uh why do these things persist
amidst
you know kind of this uh this
meritocratic aspect of science which
should be
these are brilliant scientists they
should not be uh persecuted their
they should i mean what do we do do we
have you know blind uh
blind um submission in terms of like
author names or
or even male female distinctions how
would you cure this in the
i just care about science right now
because the worst thing i think for
society is if scientists
are undermined by becoming too political
and i always say my show is
apolitical because there's no republican
comment there's no
uh democratic asteroid out there so how
do we do it and if you are in charge of
say the journal the academic science
side of things
how could you make it equitable for
these people who have
like we have we both described suffered
in the past
so but just to make sure that i
understand are you saying that
today there is still endemic
bigotry going on in all sorts of
contexts in the university
i don't mean in the cafeteria between
two individuals when we're hiring
post docs and professors there's endemic
racism is that your community no i don't
think so actually i push back on that i
have a podcast coming out soon with
professor gentry patrick who happens to
be african-american neurobiologist at uc
san diego
and you know i said look when they say
that the system is racist
but then they say that they're not
racist i don't know a single person
who'll say that they're racist
but i have had you know just just teeth
gnashingly
uh frustrating discussions with
colleagues will they'll characterize
african-american contributions
in ways that are uh you know that i have
not heard them characterize so you're
right maybe it's not
it's not the department chair you know
he or she is not going to get up and say
well this african-american
uh obviously that doesn't happen so uh
but but i haven't witnessed it and for
not even in hiring just other academics
talking in a negative way
and i always correct them uh especially
when it's about friends of mine or
people that i know and i've told
the thing that i do as an advocate you
know as i try to be
i tell the black i tell my
african-american colleagues i say this
is what people are saying about
about you and i want you to know this
person's an enemy or this person
not to like because i'm using their own
words so but but getting back
yeah so would you say that there isn't
cis there is no
systemic racism within say the academic
scientific journal system or what have
you as nature magazine
this summer testified that there was
invidious racism within all of academia
or science no i don't think look i think
that
the the current university is some of
the
uh least racist place that one can find
everybody is afraid to utter a word
that might sound phonetically as though
it were
a racial slur as we know from the guy i
think at usc
who said a word in chinese that sounded
like it was a
racial slur and then he was put on leave
so i think that generally speaking
universities
are a bastion of sterile
non-racism because everybody is afraid
of their shadow does that mean that in
the past there hasn't been systemic
racism
or sexism or whatever of course not
there has been that
but again in the in in the in the quest
to
create an equitable playing field we
don't
institute mechanisms that perpetuate
that which we're trying to solve
so for example when you have granting
agencies now and surely it has to be
that you know this because
you apply for grants you now have to as
part of your grant
put what have you done in the past to
adhere to die
principles and if you win this grant
what will you do
to pursue die principles and i receive a
million of these examples
from all sorts of anonymous sources
as emails one of my friends who is a
physical chemist at
a fellow sister university in montreal a
very accomplished physical chemist
had his so the equivalent of your nsf
the national science foundation
so had his grants stopped at the die
statement
in other words they didn't go past that
into the actual content of the grant
because they didn't feel that his die
statement
was sufficiently progressive this is not
some esoteric thing that i'm making up
these are real people
so is there individual racism when
people are speaking
at the lunchroom undoubtedly because the
the human heart is dark and racism is
not going to be eradicated from the
possible behavioral repertoire of the
human condition but
is there systemic racism and sexism at
the university today
no let me give you an example a few
years ago i reported on a
on data from the u.s government showing
that across
four levels of education so the
associate's degree
bachelor's degree master's degree and
doctorate
so four levels of education across five
racial groups
so there's so the the table is is a four
by five there are 20 cells
in every single one of those cells so
please
listen carefully brian and fellow
listeners
every single one of those cells women
outnumbered men in 20 out of
20 cells all racial groups all
educational levels
women outnumbered men does that not
imply that the data is suggesting
that we don't now need more help for
women in the university
40 years ago that would have been true
right today it is no longer true
so if you are a epistemologically honest
person
who is a truth teller then you would
adjust your victimhood narrative
it was true that women were kept out of
academia it is no longer true today
but yet we hang on to that victimology
currency i just
retweeted a a other data set that shows
that 92
of sex specific grants in the u.s are
granted to women
eight percent to men is that correct do
you support that
i'm asking you generally is that good
well no i mean obviously as a
meritocratic process we should be
supporting the best science uh
you know in a blind way but actually now
i'm noticing that
and people are telling me that even
things that were held like blind
auditions
those are now being claimed are are not
acceptable anymore and
and the thing that really spoke to me in
your book is you think like a scientist
your um your role in kind of trying to
find
optimization problems you know kind of
finding where is the min
max kind of trade off in this so i want
to get into this
uh because you know the the thing i
always hated about when i
was on a book tour and and your book is
you know in a different order of
magnitude in terms of
you know popularity sales etc so you
don't need you need my help like you
know i need to pitch for the san diego
padres
uh but the point is um you know that uh
i don't like it when i was asked well
like explain your entire book
every single chapter of your book and so
that basically my readers can save you
know 12.99
so i you know you've talked a lot about
the book on the sad truth i want to get
into like your brain because i don't get
too often a chance to chat with folks
like you
um and i want to ask you in in
particular uh
if you were running a university and
this is a goal of yours
you're a war refugee you're from the
middle east you you're from a minority
within a majority country
um uh now you're living you know in a
foreign country from your homeland and
and for many years
even now you couldn't go back to lebanon
it's no secret that you were
you speak about the childhood trauma
that you endured as a child refugee it's
almost unimaginable the things that you
describe
uh i was thinking my young kids going
through it uh
very reminiscent of some of the the
holocaust material i've had on some
holocaust survivors rose schindler
who wrote a book about her experiences
in auschwitz her husband's experiences
in the death camps as well they both
survived obviously but um
but you know the kind of idyllic nature
that their lives were like
before the holocaust in her case growing
up in moomkach which is um
which is sort of halfway between hungary
eastern europe
uh before she was deported to the death
camps and luckily survived
um she talks about as idyllic and i want
to say were there any
um i what was childhood like before you
were fled lebanon i'm very i have a lot
of lebanese friends and
and they're some of the most you know
warm i mean engaging
a life-affirming people so there must be
something wonderful about lebanon what
was it like for you as a kid
great thank you for that personal
question uh look
it is absolutely true that uh you know
we lived a wonderful
life in lebanon until we didn't right so
it's kind of like the guy's walking
around thinking that he's been eating
well and exercising then he drops dead
of a heart attack well you don't say
but how could it be he died of a heart
attack 10 minutes earlier he was jogging
well that's how heart attacks happen
right
so so yes we were walking around jogging
and eating good food
until we had to run really quickly
because our heads were going to be
detached from the rest of our bodies now
the fact that we lived a good life in
lebanon
this doesn't imply that there wasn't
always an
asterisk so i always knew that we were
different in lebanon i always knew that
i shouldn't be
advertising loudly that we're jewish
it's not as though it was a secret
people can just go to the
synagogue to see who's showing up on
saturday so it's not like
it you know it was truly hidden but you
had to
know your place jew don't cause too much
trouble right
i tell a story of when uh we were in
school
and the uh teacher says what okay
students stand up each of you
and tell us what you want to be when you
grow up and one person gets up says i
want to be a policeman i want to be a
soccer player i want to be a doctor
i want to be a jew killer and everybody
laughs and
claps that wasn't during the civil war
that was part of my
idyllic pre-civil war in the paris of
the middle east
and the paris of the middle east so even
in the context of
beautiful tolerant progressive
paris of the middle east there was jew
hatred
that was lurking in every corner if
people didn't know you were jewish
they might approach you and say oh my
god it's raining today
effing jews i got diabetes effing jews
my wife cheated on me effing jews
there's always a plot by which the jews
are behind
each of the maladies and ills that is
happening in our society
that's happening not in yemen or saudi
arabia it's happening in progressive
lebanon
so yes it was idyllic in that we came
from a prominent family we were very
well connected
lebanon as you said is made up of in
french you say bon vivon
people who know how to live we party
hard we play hard we have a sense of
humor
we're hospitable we're warm and so i do
have fond memories of lebanon
but i also know that i was always
considered different and so one of the
stories that i tell in chapter one
is when we clear the air airspace of
lebanon my mother and the captain
says yeah you know where i'm going with
this and the captain says that we've
cleared it
she puts the uh the the jewish
symbol star of david o'hai and then says
now you can wear this and not hide your
identity
now that didn't come from the fact that
i only hid my identity during the civil
war
it comes from the fact that we always
knew that
we had to have the luggage ready in case
something went wrong
so there was a tension my parents loved
lebanon
that's why we were part of the last
remaining jews in lebanon because we did
have a good life there
all of the jews had left lebanon oh in
the 20th century we were part of the
last
small group of jews and as a matter of
fact my parents loved lebanon so much
that they went back right exactly they
went back from so we came to montreal in
1975
in 1980 on one of their return trips
middle of
massive butchery civil war they were
kidnapped by fatah
well that's a testament to the fact that
it's as if they preferred the butchery
of the middle east
than the snow of montreal right well
yeah
i didn't tell the story in the book but
let me share it here
exactly when we moved to montreal
uh my father had gotten some ticket like
a parking ticket or whatever
for parking somewhere and so his first
response was
okay so who is the cop that i have to
grease
so that i stopped receiving tickets to
which someone i don't know who it was
one of my siblings my siblings are much
older than me
had said well you know this is not how
it happens here
dad we you know they don't do that here
this way to which he answered
what kind of barbaric country is this
so from his perspective the fact that
there was no way by which you can
you you know use your uh bakshish and so
on to
to greece this person that person was
outlandish who
follows the rules like this this is a
grotesque disgusting country
right so that shows you the difficulty
of having to acculturate to a new land
yeah i i thought you were going to tell
me that he went back because he forgot
his belt
you described what my god you really
remember all the stories
the book is very vivid and you know i
want to talk more about the book
and books in general uh because you know
as carl sagan
uh uh who i've had his wife and his
daughter
on my show on my podcast uh he said a
book is proof that human beings can work
magic in that you know i can have not
your voice literally in the audiobook
although it was
read by a wonderful narrator but
actually the printed word could have
been written hundreds of years ago and
still communicate to me
uh across the centuries that's what carl
sagan said is proof that books are magic
the human mind can work magic i now have
co-opted that and say a podcast is proof
that
human beings can work magic because you
know this will be saved for
you know for the 20 listeners of my of
my show uh but
um i don't want to talk about the book
and especially being a jew
um and i always thought you know
seinfeld was not jewish enough
and so i wanna i wanna talk about
judaism i i know that you're
you're either an extreme you know
militant agnostic
or or you're uh or more atheistic in in
your leanings
can we talk a little bit about that for
a bit sure okay so
i want to say because judaism looms
large in your story
and and and who you are is deeply
endemically jewish and
of course you know judaism you can never
leave it's like the mafia
you know you can never get pulled out of
it um but there's a difference in
and kind of the affirmative judaism
where you take part in some
rituals for cultural reasons even even
if only cultural reasons
uh but then when you if you completely
shun it which i don't see you doing
you're
very proud of being jewish but but i
want to ask you
why why don't you practice i'm not i'm
not speaking from a place like my friend
ben shapiro who's who's
you know ultra orthodox in a sense but
um i consider myself scientifically
i consider myself to um you know there's
a scientific method
and i call it the semitic method and
it's sort of i like to
explore things if i'm if i'm if i call
myself an agnostic which i do
uh i call myself a devout agnostic
meaning that i i
go to temple i i do i teach my children
about the commandments i do observe
kosher you know the the technical laws
of kosher not every single thing alita
but uh but the bottom line is i view
that judaism is not just like
makes you feel like an outsider and so
you you kind of got this in group bias
but it's it's it's a deeply
wisdom-filled way to live one's life
and i want to ask you um what level of
observance do you have
and and maybe we can get into some of
your thoughts about the real g.o.d
god uh and and why or why not you have
maintained
the views that you hold so first of all
yeah can you talk about your
relationship to judaism and then to god
or laughter yeah great great questions
of course
uh so i'm not very observant although
i have waxed and waned in my observance
but usually for very earthly reasons
let me give you one story which i think
might also be another exclusive my god
are you
yeah i'm getting a lot today oops i
should have turned on the recording i i
wish i turned on the recorder now go
ahead guys
that's okay i'm taping it okay
well when i went to the only ivy league
school that matters
cornell university you mentioned earlier
carl sagan
yes who was cornell right so my father
was a teacher there my father was a
professor there
where at cornell is the math department
no no i mean which which department he
was in the math department he was the
youngest full professor
ever at cornell 27 years old math
department
oh my god so when did he leave cornell
he left in 1969 to start
co-start the math department at suny
stoney brook
ah okay well so you guys missed each
other yeah yeah yeah i'm sorry a couple
of
yeah so no so at cornell
i uh became friends with the
chabad rabbi ellie silberstein
a lovely gentleman whose wife actually
was pursuing her phd in psychology and
so
we at developmental psychology of
america so we ended up taking
uh many courses together and so on uh
her name was hannah
and so ellie who would you know who had
this
uh program to try to bring in all the
jewish students to
shabbat dinners and so on would invite
me to their house and so on
and we became friends and we'd have
great conversation over shabbat dinner
and one time he asked me you know god
could you do me a favor
which i knew okay i'm in trouble now uh
circumcision second circle touch-up
i'm covered there but uh could you could
you do me a favor and put on
feline every day uh and so
i i'm a man of my word so when i said
yes i ended up doing it from
so probably around the early 90s to
about maybe
you know 10 years ago wow now i did it
in part to honor him
in part as a ritual to
remembrance of my belonging to this
group
but it is truly done without any
sort of cosmic theological things i
don't believe that there is a guy
in the sky who prescribed that that's
infinite it's a way
for me to say uh i belong to this
fan club i don't mean to vulgarize it no
i know it really is that
right we are humans are tribal whether
we like it or not
as much as i might rail against identity
politics we are a coalitional
uh creature we do view the world as blue
versus red team
so i am very jewish and that i mean no
one has lived their judaism
more than someone who's escaped
execution lebanon it's not ben shapiro
and it's not dennis
it's live judaism right yeah so so i can
be very jewish in that i belong to a
group
that's very old that has maintained its
traditions
that has wonderful accomplishments as
again as a group
so i could be proud of that
belongingness without
ascribing all the forgive me for saying
it not to be belittle
all the bugabooga stuff because once you
go down the bugabooga stuff
it's endless right because brian keating
decides
that he decides where he's going to stop
his kashrut
story but in a sense forgive me for
saying you're being a hypocrite you're
engaging in
cafeteria judaism right it's true decide
which part you like which one
well i'm in in a sense too pure for that
if i'm gonna eat shrimp
i'm gonna have pork i'm not gonna create
a new form of
cashew root that allows me to eat pork
but not shrimp or vice versa
so i don't i don't buy all that stuff so
i'm extremely jewish in my
identity in a very earthly way i'm very
very
minimally jewish when it comes to all
the religious rituals does that does
that answer the question
yeah it does and i want to just follow
up a tiny bit to say that um
when we when i when i think about
judaism and it could go for any religion
catholicism
islam etc the the notion that there is
this
well of of truth or this well of
resources i view judaism in terms of
resources so
like any other resource like some
resources i need i i need to
drive on public roads but i don't
necessarily need social security or
welfare or something like that
but when i see the vast repository of
wisdom of tradition
and i say well this is this is of value
to me like i used to think ah the
ten commandments who who needs it uh but
now i look at it i'm like you know i'm
not tempted to worship idols
uh i'm a sophisticated man i'm a new
york uh you know
liberty libertarian-minded jew i'm very
open i'm educated phd from ivy league
another ivy league institution maybe
not as great as cornell okay but i'm not
going to worship
bow down and worship ball or some some
golden calf
and the more i went into it and
especially in writing my book i i
discovered that there is a little uh
here's one there's a golden idol that i
was worshiping and actually you
mentioned the word nobel prize
you know about 10 as i do in my book
about the nobel prize and you mentioned
in terms of the jewish winners of it you
mentioned it in terms of
uh of of its prestige and and and how
you know certain nobel prize winners
were taken down because of their
are canceled because of their odious
views anyway i'm not talking about that
just now
but that i was worshiping idols and i do
think even even i know you're joking or
know that you're you're saying it in a
funny way but we do worship college
education to be at concordia to be at
mcgill you mentioned mcgill many many
times
as one of the best universities in the
world i think and i wonder if you agree
we have as many idols nowadays
as the ancient worshippers of baal and
and
ra et cetera it's just that we feel like
ours are more sophisticated because they
come from the king of sweden rather than
from
you know the some some guy who goes to
the bathroom in the nile so what do you
make of the idol worship of our age i
see judaism
as the ultimate fu to that that there is
one god
at most one god and uh and if that's
true you don't have to worry about your
dean
or your or your chancellor or the nobel
committee in my case i don't give an
f about that because i know that there
may not be a god
but but at least i'm not worshiping all
these ancillary
uh supplements to him uh in that way
so i the way i would answer it and i i
hope that it will be satisfactory to you
is
is i can pers i can instantiate
that commandment without couching it
in religious uh language so if you
remember in chapter one of the president
mind i talk about
the two life ideals by which
i live in a sense if i can now use
religious
language i pray at the altar of truth
and freedom and therefore i don't
pray at the altar of false gods what do
i mean by that
is there is nothing to me that's more
important than the pure
pursuit of truth and freedom as a matter
of fact earlier today
i was walking with my wife i said you
know i'm i'm not trying to
to to blow smoke up your proverbial
behind i said you know i'm really
excited to talk later to brian because
i love long firm format chats and i'm
sure we're gonna have a great time
so right uh there is a magisterial
quality to life if you pursue it in a
pure way if you
truly are committed to the cerebral life
if you are committed to truth
uh the reason why i'm so indignant often
in my public engagements because i'm
really angry when people attack truth
i'm really angry when there are
intrusions against freedom
so i could pray at the altar
of truth and freedom and so i'm
instantiating
instantiating that commandment without
couching it
in bugabooga but does that make sense
yeah it does it does i just wanna i just
you know because you're so open-minded
about so many different topics i can't
resist
like if i look at you look you're in
canada amer you know the 51st state
or great state to the north uh you look
at the u.s constitution
it's pretty good it's not perfect it had
some flaws in it uh if you look at it
you know
uh and you say could this be a model for
how to start a new nation
somewhere i don't know uh you know eric
weinstein wants to move to
saint helena or some place in the middle
of the caribbean where he thinks we're
going to get a whole bunch of jews down
there or something i don't know what
he's thinking about
but but i look at it and then say the
fifth commandment uh honor thy mother
and thy father so that thy days may be
long
on the earth you exemplify the honor
that you attribute i don't know if your
parents are still with us or not but
they are they are thank god so you look
at that
and you look at the honor that the
reverence that you speak about them
in the book then you talk about how your
children are and how protective and how
do
and and you see that because you honored
your parents
i believe you will be honored by your
children your children will not only
honor you because of who raised them but
they will see you as a role model to
your child now what's the second part of
that commandment you know it's
interesting
it's the only commandment in the ten
commandments that has a reward
you know most people think of god as a
celestial butler as dennis prager puts
it you know it's just afraid and then
he'll suspend the laws of physics
but actually the end of the uh fifth
commandment says um
so that your days may be long on the
earth now it clearly doesn't mean that
you're gonna live forever
uh you know or that you're gonna be
protected from all sorts of harm but
what will it mean
in my interpretation it means that your
your days will have more meaning because
your biological children and if you're
lucky enough to have them as you and i
do
and your ideological children as we are
both lucky
through our phd students and we'll talk
about the the
the genealogy of physics i can trace
mine back to the 1600s 1500s
and uh and it's sort of been passed on
and that's very meaningful to me
um but i want to say now you see the
there's two commandments you know then
there's
there's laws against coveting and and we
covet so much in society i coveted
you know uh as i said you know my
neighbor's nobel prize not his ass
uh or his wife's ass uh but but
nevertheless um
you know so i guess i'm asking at what
point would you start to consider
again i i actually i i would not have
asked you to do to film it i would have
asked you to
uh study talmud because you have that
mind you have a
so what is why do you like this
conversation because it's two minds
together connected across
wonderful technology um and we're able
to have this conversation connecting our
minds
uh piecing out arguing where necessary
but doing so
in an honest intellectual uh empath
empathetic manner
but that's what the talmud's about the
talmud is an adversarial
but but also provisional kind of
learning scheme and never says this is
the final law
it says this guy said this rabbi hillel
said this rabbi shamai said this
they fought about it and then blah blah
so i think
i would recommend you do that prayer is
very difficult for me i i find it very
woo-woo
and as you're saying kind of and i
almost feel like it has been
co-opted by other institutions such as
the one where the most jews adhere to
which is buddhism
and i want to ask you like in any other
realm of your life do you meditate for
example i'm curious
so i don't meditate okay but i do
exercise a lot although my body doesn't
seem to suggest well remember you know
god is supposed to be expanded
so according to god you're supposed to
get you've got permission a heter from
the almighty now that is something you
have in common with another
bearded intellectual jew who is not
practicing
uh that you do not meditate with noam
chomsky and
i want to talk i want to talk a little
bit about your feelings on noam chomsky
i talked to ben about this a little bit
he didn't uh he didn't spend too much
time talking about it uh when we had a
chat
but i know that you've had great
difficulties with him is that primarily
because of uh views that he has
politically again we're not i'm not a
political
i'm not like you uh or is it or is it
yeah go ahead let me
tease a tree i'll be teasing is it a
part for you uh so i one of the
uh sections in the book is called uh
six degrees of full causality right
where i can give you some phenomenon and
i ask you in six
or fewer illusory causal links to
explain
why the amazonian frog died and it's due
to orange man bad
okay well one instantiation of
six degrees of focusality is six degrees
of gnome chomsky
so i give you a malady around the world
and you have to link it to the us
military industrial complex in six or
fewer steps
there you go that's why i despise dom
chomsky because he's a buffoon
he did something great with his
universal grammar he should have stuck
to that
but then when you become the proverbial
to every and i i have these quotes in
the book you know i'm paraphrasing now
to the one who's holding the the hammer
the world looks like it's made of nails
that's exactly what norm chomsky's been
doing for 40 years
every single thing is associated to the
us
he you know he's never met a dictator
that he doesn't love he hasn't
so he he suffers from regrettably a
lack of epistemic humility you mentioned
earlier when you went to give a talk and
someone asked you about global warming
and you said well you know i don't know
enough about global well guess what i'm
exactly like you if you ask me about
global warming
so you know what i just don't know
enough about it if you ask me about
whether the pros and cons of
legalization of marijuana i just don't
know enough about it
but if you ask me about things
that as i explained in chapter seven
i've already built the nomological
network of cumulative evidence for it
then i'm coming at you with all of the
swagger that my tsunami of evidence
allows me to walk with right in other
words i know what i know
and i know what i don't know noam
chomsky doesn't know what he doesn't
know
he knows about everything and it's
always due
to the us military-industrial complex
and the rest of his [ __ ]
so that's why i have an aversion to him
because he doesn't
exude for me the type of in other words
i could be completely wrong but i have a
sense when i see someone whether they
are
somebody that i would like to hang out
with whether they're cool
and he doesn't strike me like he's that
guy because he's the type of guy who's
going to be pontificating over me
all evening and i don't like these kinds
of fellows when you uh think about
establishing uh uh your dream utopian
university
sad university i want to ask you first
of all
what courses would you make mandatory
for purely intellectual
broadening of the human mind of a young
person's mind what would you make on the
core curriculum of sad university
a great question uh probably how to
think right and so maybe i can go to
to that section in the book in answering
your question so in chapter 7
it's i discuss how to seek truth and i
argue that you one of the most powerful
tools that i can think of
epistemologically in
establishing the veracity of a position
is to build what i call normological
networks of cumulative evidence and so
let me
draw a parallel with the original grand
daddy of such
a process so charles darwin you know
that white supremacist
charles darwin had in developing his
theory of
uh theory of evolution natural selection
he didn't collect data from 30
undergrads in
ohio state university and then say
goodnight everybody i've proven my
theory
over almost three decades he assiduously
collected data
from an extra ordinarily different
distinct lines of evidence from geology
from paleontology from ecology from
biodiversity from animal husbandry
from comparative morphology which when
you put it all together
it it it completed the puzzle right
and so put that now in a modern context
i argue that what charles darwin did
150 years ago is how we need to
address questions about the veracity of
a position
and let me draw an example which i
discussed in the book
so if i'm trying to convince you brian
that
toy preferences are not socially
constructed
in other words it's not mommy and daddy
who are sexist pigs who tell
little johnny to play with the blue
truck and little linda to play with the
pink doll
it's not about that there are some
biological reasons why
there is a sex specificity of choice
what are the types of distinct lines of
evidence i can get
in proving my point to you so this is
not a literature review
literature review is actually a lot more
restrained in its epistemological power
it's not a meta-analysis it's much
bigger than that it is saying
what is all of the possible universal
data from
every imaginable source across time
periods
across cultures across disciplines
across frameworks that would prove my
position so
i won't build you the whole neurological
network but i'll give you a few so that
you can get a sense well
i could take children who are in the
pre-socialization stage of their
cognitive
development meaning that they they're
they're too young to have been
socialized
and i could show you that they already
exhibit that sex specificity of toy
preferences
that's already putting a a death blow to
the social construction
lower limit on it right exactly but i'm
going to keep going i could go to
comparative psychology
and look at other animals as i mentioned
earlier verve monkeys reese's monkeys
and chimpanzees and show you that their
infants exhibit that sex specificity
well now i've shown you from
developmental psychology from
comparative psychology but i'm not done
yet
i could get you data from pediatric
endocrinology what does that mean
so little girls who suffer from
congenital adrenal hyperplasia this is a
endocrinological disorder that
masculinizes the behavior and morphology
of little girls
i could take these little girls and show
you that if they suffer from this
disorder
their toy preferences are reversed they
become like those of boys
i could look at data from several
thousand years ago
funerary monuments from ancient greece
where they have depictions of
boys and girls and i could show you that
they depict them playing with the same
types of toys that we're playing with
today
so bit by bit through history through
time periods through culture
i can dismantle the possibility of your
position
so what i would do to answer your
original question
is before teaching people content
what is the capital of france i would
teach them
how to think because then that univ that
universal epistemological key
i could use it in any landscape you want
me to use it
would you uh teach chomsky would you
teach zinn what
how would you even as a cautionary
example yeah i mean it's for the same
reason by the way that i would teach
religion so even though i'm not i might
not be a very religious person
there are as a historical document
as a literary document as a moral
document and at times immoral document
i can teach these
these uh manuscripts
uh as part of my greater knowledge so so
i don't have a lot of people think that
oftentimes when i critique
some of the idea pathogens that come out
of the humanities and the social
sciences
i'm denigrating those not at all
you can study uh chaucer and shakespeare
in a very serious way
you could study the philosophy of
aesthetics in a very beautiful and so
it's not as though
oh you're a physicist or you're a real
thinker or you're a sociologist you must
have failed in
physics not at all i don't have a
natural hierarchy but what i'm saying
though is
always be committed to reason to logic
not necessarily always a scientific
method because you can't necessarily
study chaucer
using the scientific method but you
can't be decoupled
from our reasoning faculties that's all
i'm saying
um you have a few more minutes scott
sure that's okay
um so you're very prolific um
uh on social media especially twitter
and youtube
where you've had you know hundreds of
thousands of followers subscribers etc
um i want to ask you there's a quote
from uh from george orwell from
animal farm where the pig is talking to
benjamin the donkey
and the pig says i've got this short
tail it's useless
and you have such a luxurious long tail
benjamin the donkey
uh and the donkey says yes the the lord
gave me
a long tail to swat away the flies but
i'd rather
not have the tail because i don't need
the tail in other words
i'd rather not have the flies and not
need the tail uh you've got a lot of
flies on you
um more than mike pence did at the vice
presidential debate last week
um would you trade it i mean are you
happy that you've achieved this level of
of really renown
in in in terms of your your presence on
social media
it comes at must it must come at great
consequence i mean you need security
when you travel
do you regret it as i guess what i'm
asking i don't regret it because
i i'm so thrilled when i see
how people respond respond positively
to my efforts and it's not because
i'm narcissistic or arrogant but when
somebody sends me a
message saying you know i was gonna quit
university or i was gonna kill myself or
i was gonna whatever some some
and it was watching your stuff that got
me out of it well it's kind of hard not
to be
touched by it and not to be invigorated
by that love
but you are right that it comes at a
great cost you're right that there's
been some security issues
listen uh a few years ago so as you
might imagine when i
walk down the street i you know often
will get stopped by tons of people
it's always been luckily not once has it
been negative out of
thousands of times but you don't know
when that next negative one will be
right
who the person who truly did give you
that death threat will act on it
uh if i think it was maybe two years ago
i was walking out of my house and i was
in the driveway
and i heard someone say excuse me and
usually i
kind of know what's going to come next
it's going to be you know are you got
sad right
and so i turned and i was just with my
wife my kids were already at school
and i said yes and he goes are you
godsad
i said yes he goes oh do you mind if i
come over and shake your hands and i
said
sure so then he leaves then the rest of
the day i was in a complete panic
why because now someone knows
exactly where i live right like that guy
could sure be a fan
but maybe tomorrow i'll say something
that he doesn't like and i'm he's no
longer a fan
and he could go on the internet and say
this is where it gots out
so should've said i'm nom chomsky
exactly uh so so the
99 of the notoriety and you know
accolades and love and so on is great
but it does come at a cost it also
because you're now you know you're i'm
recognized a lot more and so on
oftentimes i'm very defensive about what
i'm with my family or my children if you
notice on my social media
i never put photos of them my wife if i
take a picture of her it's always over
her head yeah
my children because i'm you know the the
the world is a very ugly place and the
ones who hate you
won't stop at only attacking you they'll
start attacking your young children your
wife and so on
so that's the part that i don't like
because they didn't choose
that life so sometimes when someone says
oh can i take a picture with you or a
selfie or something
i always ask them very nicely please
don't take a picture of my family so
what
so that would probably be the only part
that i dislike the rest of it
i receive so much love and kindness that
who would not want
i see it as a sort of a manifestation of
of entropy and network theory
you you of course know about this that
the that the number of pairwise
connections in a network of n
elements grows as n squared so in in
other words if you have you know
a family that's twice as big as another
family you have potentially you know
four times the happiness
uh but but then conflicts arise between
single individual pairs
so that kind of grows as n not n squared
so the ratio
you're bringing me back to graph theory
and analysis of algorithms in my math
and computer science based i love it i
love it
uh so my theory is that that's why we
should all have big families we should
have you know big friend networks that's
probably why you know these networks are
so successful
but um as with evolution the number of
you know in a quaternary base pair
system like dna
that can grow much faster even than you
know to than you know geometric
functions
and i wonder if you know things like
twitter are evolving according to these
same laws
where eventually it won't grow like the
cost will grow almost as the benefits
and then
at a certain point we'll have
diminishing returns and i want to ask
you
obviously ben shapiro takes a sabbath
every every uh
every week for 25 hours dave rubin takes
a sabbath for a month
every every year uh can you do that can
you
um stop the put the rapier wit back in
the sheath
uh you know are you able to turn it on
and turn it off
uh i've tried with
intermittent success so for example i
try to institute
a shapiro model or a reuben model
with not nearly as as discipline the
success as they do
but i think i need to aspire to that
because i think for my
mental health it would really be good
because what ends up happening
uh is that and i haven't tested this
endocrinologically but i suspect that
it can't be good for my cortisol levels
yeah because
what ends up happening is you're
constantly
as kind of the forgive me for putting it
this way it sounds
grand but as sort of the apostle of
truth
i'm always looking for the next imbecile
to slay
right so i'm kind of the guy at the bar
looking who's saying
all right who wants who wants who wants
next at me that's your dopamine that's
your yeah it's your fight you have no
flight
yeah you have no flight gene but you
have all fight yeah
exactly and that is exhausting because
uh for all of the love that i receive
i'm not looking for the love on social
media i'm looking to slay the idiots
and so i'm constantly in as you said
fight mode
even if it's politely even if it's uh
you know jocular
in a jocular way and that i think could
not actually it could be exhausting so
if i'm able to institute something akin
to shapiro or ruben i think i would be
much healthier for it all right great if
you'll indulge me i've got three final
questions that i asked all my guests
and i want to take this opportunity when
is the next time i'll
get to chat with uh with a god uh so the
first question is a simple one can you
provide a geometric quantization of
space time that unifies all four forces
of nature into one theory of everything
i'll give you five seconds okay okay no
no is there a theory of everything and
behavioral economics is there kind of a
master
you know uh and this consumption
darwinian darwinian consumption is there
a parrot a catechism that i can use to
sound smart at the next time i ever get
together for a cocktail party
beautiful question so uh i would say
that evolutionary theory is
the overriding meta framework to
understand human behavior so
let me explain what i mean by that
whether you are a biologist at the
cellular level
or the uh you know ecological level or
the organism level
or the population level irrespective of
the unit of analysis you work under
there are no pro darwinists versus
anti-darwinists right
there are no chemists who are pro
periodic table and anti-periodic table
so there is some level of conciliance a
term that i love that was reintroduced
by the lexicon
by e.o wilson so in my own work i
in trying to introduce evolutionary
psychology into the behavioral sciences
in general and consumer behavior in
particular
i argue that you could never have a
consilient science
of human behavior that is bereft of
evolutionary thinking
and so to answer your question while
there isn't a law
that explains our behavior there is a
meta framework
under which all human phenomena are
subsumed and that's called evolutionary
theory
okay good so that is a wonderful uh
thing for me to keep my back pocket uh
the next thing i want to ask you i do
ask this of all my guests
uh that uh it revolves around the
concept in hebrew it's known as a zava
ah it's a it's a document that
translates roughly to ethical will not
material will which undoubtedly you'll
give
most of your great wealth to to me uh
you know from this you know the
concordia
chair salary is going to go the mulsin
legacy is going to come i just want the
beer i i really do
i'm aching for some some molson and i
would never never do that labaths
i don't know does molten own lebats
maybe they do i don't know i don't know
oh you call yourself a canadian i bet
you don't even know what uh
what a uh what is it called the penalty
boxes in hockey i don't know you i do
know what that is you talk a lot about
soccer and a football in the book and i
thought that was great but anyway let's
get back to that sport
yes okay the ethical will so uh what
what
wisdom what kind of knowledge not
material thing would you most want to
bequeath not only to your
biological children but to ideological
children that you
influence in your career what sorts of
of wisdom
would you most want to provide for their
future
wisdom in general it has to be ethical
wisdom
it could be either it could be either
actually
wisdom i would probably say uh
live it's gonna sound cliche because i'm
not the first one to say this but i
truly do mean it
live a meaningful and purposeful life so
i don't wake up ever in the morning and
i say
ah life sucks there's nothing for me to
do there is all i'm like a
kid that's on a sugar rush right
there's always a million cool things if
i've got nothing but i'll write a
psychology today article if i don't feel
like doing that i'll work on a peer
review paper if i don't want to do that
i'll work on the book perspective
perspectives for my next book
if not i'll talk to brian keating on a
show if not that
so there is always something that's
compelling me forward
that's exciting there's always something
around the corner now life is very short
and it's tragic if we don't live life in
the way that i just described it now
of course the the regrettable part is
not not everyone will find that passion
in other words
i was fortunate enough to have found a
way
to you know instantiate that purposeful
and meaningful life
but what i would say to people is you
know don't go into accounting because
your dad said that it should be
it's a good career that's a safe but
then you wake up at 57 and say i hated
my life as
i really wanted to be a dancer because
you only really get one crack at this
unless you believe you're a religious
person you're going to be reincarnated
or you're going to go to heaven
but short of that in the earthly realm
you're going to get one crack at it
every second count so please live your
life with passion with honesty
and with purpose and meaning yeah and
with gusto and i was just thinking as
you said that like if i told you when
you were getting your
you know your degree at mcgill that you
know somehow is going to let down your
mother if you only got an mba
yeah that's a real jewish mother i mean
you i thought mine was was pretty tough
but but yours do you want me to tell
that story very quickly yeah
let's do it okay so this i was talking
about that story in the context of
juxtaposing it against the juicy
smollette with his victimology narrative
and i was saying that look uh depending
on the environment that you come from
the the bar of how you achieve
excellence is set in very different ways
and so the story that i tell is that
after i finished my mba so at that point
i'd had
a math and computer science degree and
an mba with a mini thesis and operations
research
this is pretty fancy mathematics stuff
yeah slacker slacker
exactly and so i was then going on to
pursue my phd i knew i wanted to go into
academia but
one of the places i had been accepted
for my psg was uc irvine
my brother at the time lived in southern
california where he lived
for much of the past 35 years since
about 1984.
and he had a very successful business in
the software industry and he was trying
to convince me
well you know why don't you put on you
the proverbial suit for a couple of
years you know you just got your mba
if you want to go back and do your phd
later that's great but you know get out
there and get some
excuse me life you know work experience
and so i i
i entertained his his suggestion and i
spent the day hanging out with him at
his office now when i returned
home to montreal my mother had caught
wind that my brother was trying to
convince me to maybe
you know put a hole on my phd so she
takes me to a
another room to kind of speak to me
privately and says you know i heard that
story
do you want people to remember you as
somebody who dropped out of school
and so from her perspective it would
have brought great great shame and i
would have been a total loser and a
dropout
if i had stopped after my mba now of
course it's not as though i went and did
my phd to please her
but it's that it gives you a sense of
the type of expectations
that we can either instill in our
children or not so that's where that's
and actually i found some a harmonious
resonance with what you said just a
minute ago and the answer
you're basically saying take advantage
of all the opportunities that you have
never be bored because life is too
interesting to be boring
and the third thing is like you don't
know what the future is going to bring
as you said uh in the 90s if i told you
get
actually uh you're going to be a
basically not a tv star but you're going
to be a screen star with literally
millions and
tens of millions of people and and by
the way you're gonna get paid
from youtube uh you're gonna get paid
for some of your videos and they don't
get demonetized
you're gonna get paid by some service
that hosts your videos for
free and then you're going to be world
renowned on this platform that goes in
the phone that fits in your pocket that
has
what the hell are you talking about
right it's unbelievable so that's my
advice to my kid like
we don't know where this is going to go
the hockey stick of exponential
technology as peter diamandis and others
have talked about
is too difficult to predict you know if
you if you're going to lose
in a year and you do so one percent a
day you won't lose that final
five pounds until the last like month or
two months of a year imagine you're
gonna
it's gonna take five months to lose two
pounds you're gonna be like wow forget
it i'm never gonna do it but then those
last couple the last
exponential doubling period that's where
the hockey stick hits you
and we're living through that now so now
is not the time to be bored i want to
talk the last two questions involve
technology one is going deep into the
future and one is going to go back to
the past
going into the future if you've seen the
movie 2001 a space odyssey stanley
kubrick
i have not oh you should see it okay
well then maybe i'll skip this question
it's really about uh but but maybe i can
ask in a different way
what material object would you put on a
time capsule
uh or a book or something if you knew it
had to last for it was going to last for
a billion years
uh so could it be that a cell phone
that allows us to connect to all of the
accumulated
knowledge in the world could that be it
it could but i i don't know are they
going to use like uh google
and the and the year you know 1 billion
2020 i don't know
it could be language they'll understand
language they'll understand music
they'll have senses and so forth but
they won't be able to plug in that usb
cork that you showed me earlier so i
guess i i would answer
whatever device or mechanism that allows
us to
retain as much of the collective wisdom
that we have so far
that's the equipment i would use i see
you as an optimist
is that true i am an optimist
i do worry about things in the sense
that but usually the worries
are uh introspective uh right so for
example
i always tell the story that when i go
to bed at night the way that i decide
whether i can sleep or not
is because of my very exacting code of
personal conduct did i do everything i
can however big or small
to make the world a better place today
did i not that i shy away from an
opportunity to correct someone
when they uttered some nonsense and if
if i say that i did walk away then i
feel like a fraud and i'll be
an insomnia and that's why i always take
on any battle that comes my way in the
defense of truth so
usually my worries are introspective i
have
great moral scrupulosity i'm always
making sure that
i talk about this in chapter one of the
book right about my purity bubble and
you know my mother telling me you know
the world
doesn't abide according to your purity
bubblegum so
i think that my worries are of that form
but otherwise i'm a very
optimistic bon viva uh very effusive yes
so i hate to tell you but that's like
another
concept from judaism that you've uh
you've i can't escape my judaism no no
but you've delightfully
uh i would say evolved it i was going to
say perverted it but i'm going to say
evolved it
uh because that's the inventory that you
must make an accounting on your nasham
on your soul
you're supposed to do that every day
before you go to sleep the shema relates
to you you just gave me goosebumps
it's true it's true it's very
interesting that you're divine these
derive these however you like
on your own but but i i do think it's
deeply
rooted in your memetic uh composition
but maybe rabbi silverstein of course
now when he was saying you are a very
special soul
maybe he wasn't blowing up my behind i
think so
last thing is uh revolves not going into
the future
billionaires let's go backwards in time
arthur c clarke's a third law
states and this is how i got the name
for the pog so his first law is any
sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from magic
which michael shermer perverted into
saying any sufficiently advanced
technology is indistinguishable from god
not god god but god and then his second
law
arthur c clarke's is uh for every expert
there's an equal and opposite expert i
like that one
but his third law says that the only way
to discover the limits of the possible
is to venture a little bit past them
into the impossible that's the name of
this podcast
uh at the arthur c clarke center for
human imagination here in uc san diego
uh i want to ask you what thing or
something uh
maybe an event or or prospect for your
future what seemed impossible to a 20
year old god sod
that because you did it because i think
you have this rare quality called
courage
and that and i wish you great strength
in that and and next time maybe if
you'll indulge me in a future
conversation i want to talk about
individual versus collective like your
book is mostly about the individual
i want to figure out tactics strategies
and tips for
building a community of like-minded
parasite-free minds but but before we do
that
let's just close by asking you what
thing seemed impossible to your 20 year
old self
30 year old self but because you had the
courage to go into the impossible
now seems like you want to shake that
person and say it's going to be okay
what did you do that seemed impossible
i never thought as you kind of alluded
to earlier
that i would have the opportunities
afforded by the
the tools that we have today to have as
much
influence mimetic influence as i ended
up having so going into academia i knew
that i could
effect change but i thought that that
change would be within you know
very not narrow silos right even though
i've always been someone who's very
interdisciplinarian right as i discussed
in the book don't tell me which position
to play in soccer
don't tell me only publish in these
journals that just doesn't jive with my
brain right
i want to go everywhere i want to visit
every intellectual landscape but i
always thought that the nature of
academia was
that you you can't be lady gaga so to
speak in terms of the influence
but what i found out today as you
alluded to earlier
is that you can achieve the impossible
if you have the courage
to tackle all ideas so there are no
sacred cows that i'm afraid to talk so
a lot of the few other people who uh
someone might mention as other
professors who are in the same space as
me
if i can forgive the immodesty they
they are usually known for tackling one
idea pathogen
two idea pathogens there is no idea
pathogen there is no stupidity there is
no imbecilic idea
that is sacrosanct to me you bring on
the next conveyor belt of stupidity
and i would slay it with equal alacrity
and so
uh today what i'm able to do 20 years
ago i would have said
it's impossible i will never have such
influence and so i'm thankful that i
have the opportunity to do what i do
yeah
well god said it's been such a pleasure
to have you on the into the impossible
podcast giving us so many different
things to think about to
to learn from and i do believe that you
do have this this
uh this very vanishingly rare trade of
courage
i do hope you'll inspire other people
tell our listeners where can they find
you in what i call the spin zone where
can we find
gadsab uh so if you want to follow me on
twitter it's
at god g-a-d-s-a-a-d
if you want to uh connect with me
through my youtube channel
it's called well it's just god's ad but
the show is called the sad
truth s-a-d about four months ago i
started a podcast because
some people were complaining that they
don't want to just see the streaming on
youtube they wanted to get the audio
so then you can catch me on all of the
possible platforms that you could think
of
it's called the sad truth with dr sat
the only reason why i added with dr sat
is because some a-hole stole
the sad truth and i've written to him
several times saying look buddy i don't
want to get nasty would you take it down
he hasn't and so i had to add that extra
part uh you could
have a public facebook page and of
course please consider
purchasing the parasitic mind how
infectious ideas are killing common
sense
and thank you for being such a
delightful host thank you god it's been
a pleasure for me
enjoy the rest of your day and thank you
for spending time on the into the
impossible podcast
any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from magic
[Music]
if you enjoyed this episode of into the
impossible with professor brian keating
please subscribe comment share and
review
watch on youtube listen on itunes
spotify google player stitcher
we appreciate hearing from you and are
always open to your suggestions for
future episodes
for more information and to sign up for
professor keating's mailing list
go to dr briankeeting.com
that's dr ryan heating.com
follow professor keating on medium and
twitter at
dr brian heating dr brian heating
for more information on the clark center
go to
imagination ucs
[Music]
into the impossible is a production of
the arthur c clarke center for human
imagination
at the university of california san
diego in the division of physical
sciences
eric very director brian keating
co-director
produced by ryan keating and stuart
valco